amd is an unmet need i i have it in my mind so we'll see what we learn from here all right so
we all know about teltec study redirect study was being touched in some of the presentations
so i'm going to go to the design of the study and being directly involved in the study
i can tell you as an investigator what are the challenges we face with this study and i think
it's important to learn because when you are as a treating physician i want to try this approach
what things should be keep in mind so you know on the right side we are mentioning it's an
impressive response rate crs are great median pfs of 15 months objective response has not been
reached so it's impressive but the background is very important that what this study actually
contains these are my cois published this data already and in 12 months follow-up you can see
new england journal of medicine
you
so what is emd is i i think that's that's something is a pretty debatable uh question
and at least those who treat them they know to defining that is also kind of way how you define
them so paraskeletal paramedullary disease they are not emds it has to be bone independent growth
so that's where the consensus was in this particular study two centimeter away from
the bony lesions that's what we did and historically we can dissect
then that you know the responses are pretty poor if you have a true emd they respond very
poorly compared to patients who have paramedullary or paraskeletal plasmacytomas now the biology is
the rational was this study was done at the time when covet pandemic was being there and a lot of
concerns about the covet and infections was quite high um the the rational came up because we already
know the teclistamab was there and the talquitamab came up and plasma cells clones are pretty
heterogeneous especially those who have extramedullary disease so targeting the dual bispecific was
a novel concept and try to control the heterogeneity in the plasma cell neoplasm
now in terms of the eligibility criteria we already discussed that patients who have previous
CAR-T around 20 percent of the patients have prior CAR-T therapy and around 12 percent have received
other bcma like valentamab and few patients have fcrh5 Bispecific in this study but the
prior bcma and gprc5d bispecific was not allowed and 30 percent patients were oligosecretory and
four percent patients were non-secretory in this patients now those who do the myeloma trials we
know that a secretory patients are majority of the trials are not including them so the measurable
disease is not a matrix here you really have to do an imaging study to measure how they are
responding it and that's a very challenging part and even in this era where we have so
many innovative treatments so patterns of relapses are also changing so our approach to treatment is
our approach also needs to be redefined like how we're going to assess their responses and so that's
what's one of the challenge here here the medial lines of therapies were four uh for four and one
to ten lines of therapies the patient have received the dosing schema is slightly different
what we conventionally do the teclistamab and talcortamab but after the step up dosing we're
going for bi-weekly every two weeks regimen for these patients now here the responses are like the
first first response in 2.6 months you can see the high rates of the cr we have a pretty impressive
vgpr objective responses are quite amazing here so and the best response is reached across around
the five months timeline then there were some changes in the protocol the first thing come up
like okay those who receive vgpr we can actually switch them to once a month regimen so we can
de-escalate the treatments so here you can see the durability of the responses and median overall
level has not been reached and the preliminary data with a little bit short follow-up has already
been published in New England Journal of Medicine so you can do review that publication but it's
quite impressive where you have single agent teclistamab can give you 45 or talcotamab is
still within the 50 percent rates of emd responses and here you are combining the two getting some
impressive results now if you compare the subgroup analysis so total number of patients in this
study was 90. it's a single arm study so now we can have some criticism here because it's a single
arm study but again it's a difficult study to perform there were non-secretory cases 30 of them
now if you look at the organ emds versus the non-organ emds so organ emds are myelomas involving
the lungs stomach liver their organ emds the non-organs we define here is the lymph nodes
and the soft tissues so the responses are almost the same in the organ emd and non-organ emds but
if you look at the volume of the disease so patients who have a low volume of the disease
they actually have a better response as compared to the bulky disease and we see these things even
with the bispecifics too but with a different metrics like you know high ferritin counts high
LDH count high disease burden their responses are different compared to those who have a less bulky
disease now so safety signals are almost the same what we have previously seen in the clinical trials
but this study was criticized on one major aspect was the infections rates infections was a big
concern and we learned in this study like you have to use the IVIG and this is where a lot of these
issues within infections were happening quite early in the study like after six months those
AEs were starting to go down
and because we instituted the IVIG more aggressive on COVID vaccines which was not been really common
so those were the challenges we have but otherwise the rest of the toxins are pretty much what we have
seen in the clinical studies now here is the one of the image that has been shown in the Ash
presentation as well you can see how much bulky this patient has a disease initially but subsequent
disease responses
um
starting
starting to get better like a VGPR serologically and then reached to the CR and on the PET scan the
dual activity was less than three and those lesions were very fibrotic
now in terms of the conclusion so I think this combination of two by specifics together has a
good response rates high rates of CR we are trying to achieve the antigen escape mechanism trying to
control them but that's the best we have at this point I believe that the duration of response
has been not been reached so this is something to be considered in patients who have aggressive EMDs
and the safety profiles are quite predictable and if you transition to Q4 week regimen those toxicities
and side effects are quite minimized and with that I'm gonna stop my presentation thank you so much